me encantan los hombres y me atrae mucho
pero es que
sí
[Música]
un spectrum queer eye
más probable de me recuerda al juego del
marcador cuando hacíamos trivia si
marcábamos el séptimo bien es más
probable que haga una broma
a veces
en serio lo hiciste arrancaste
eso me hizo tantas bromas que se las
devolvía después de varias temporadas
creo que yo no las haría tal vez sea
porque él y yo tenemos una mejor
relación y le gusta arrancó la uña del
pie no es por ser narcisista pero y yo
no lo hago siempre cuando estamos muy
cansados y hemos trabajado por 12 horas
les digo me enteré de que tenemos otras
6 horas y luego tuve esa broma quién es
más probable de ganar america's next top
model'
321 ya lo siento también
afinando mirando hacia abajo cierto si
ella ha visto todos los episodios
[Risas]
de un frente unido es unánime gracias
por tu participación quién es más
probable que diga las cosas como son
es que yo soy muy británico
y él es más probable que envió un
mensaje o de un regalo sólo porque
quiere y eso es lindo ya que gracias
cariño que hace cosas bonitas por mí no
la
queremos sólo me envía mensaje sin
sentido anthony suele darles regalos con
mucha llevo de vacaciones y me llevo a
ma jin quien es más probable que
detengan en la calle en realidad están
pero voy a decir que anthony
la más divertida sólo observa el agobia
solo finge solo finge que soy anthony
seguir y que eres como alguien que se
emociona o dios mío anthony antonio
me voy a dios gracias estuvo muy
divertido
realmente ninguna ansiedad social severa
me agobiaba mucho se me acelera va el
corazón y sudaba como un loco estar en
queer eye era mi sueño
321 ya
desde que me enteré de la audición bueno
todavía no está política si no me
presenté a las audiciones porque
planeaba ir a españa y yo estaba como no
lo conseguiré solo voy a ir españa
todavía no he visto nunca vi la versión
americana si os miro bien fue
directamente donde estaba estaba en el
número 3 de la calle goya vi que
pensaste cuando viste queer eye por
primera vez sentí que encajaba sobre
todo al ver a alguien como tú que estaba
en la industria en la que yo quería
estar y recordé a todos los que durante
toda mi vida me dijeron que no llegaría
nada que nunca encontraría el amor o
tendría una relación normal que nunca
viviría una vida normal ambos cinco
demostraron que sí podía tengo que decir
que es sentí un cosquilleo profundo en
mis entrañas por kim ay dios si yo
estuviera morado de torrejón me preocupa
que las personas que ayudamos vuelvan a
caer en su antiguo estilo de vida
no estoy de acuerdo porque aunque
vuelvan a sus estilos de vida me gusta
pensar que han tenido una pequeña y
bonita experiencia llegó un momento en
el tiempo al que pueden volver cuando
estén preparados y tengan voluntad si
deciden no tomar en cuenta todo lo que
hemos dicho pues no siento por ellos
estoy de acuerdo en que a veces me
preocupa creo que desde mi categoría es
más difícil porque no van a tirar todo
lo que les diga no lo sé
bueno
si
bien esta sección se llama preguntas
calientes y hemos hecho que nuestro
público envíe preguntas que quieras para
20 vídeos muy linda me he enamorado de
otro miembro de los faith
321 ya quiero decir sí
pero oye mejor aléjate de aquí sí
cuando conocí a cada
mamá como dios mío como si quisiera que
me partiera por la mitad no pensé en eso
pero sí en que sería agradable besarme
con él creo que todos por igual éramos
muy atractivos al inicio pero luego
todos nos convertimos en hermanos y
amigos y eso eso nunca pasó pero por
supuesto al principio creo que me vaya
muy buena idea quiero mucho mucho a
todos pero no así sé lo que es un
flechazo y no se equipare a eso estoy en
total desacuerdo con él quiero decir que
es en total desacuerdo y ponerlo donde
no brilla el sol porque eso no es cierto
tengo el trabajo más difícil del
programa
321 ya vamos a ir todos por aquí
[Risas]
totalmente
si soy a pesar de que bobby tiene que
construir una casa entera siento que
trabajar con cabello es muy duro y a
veces las personas se molestan por ello
y tengo que hacer las cortes a personas
con poco cabello y eso es algo muy duro
creo que tengo el trabajo que más tiempo
consume en nuestro programa
episodios en los que tan la tuvo más
difícil en los que antonio jonathan han
estado así también todos nuestros
trabajos han sido digámosle unca ha
tenido no si no definitivamente hemos
venido jornadas muy duras esta manera
pueden formarse 12 horas en el salón
unas semanas a hacer los episodio a nash
semana con diría que una boloñesa puede
tomar de tres a cuatro horas
habían héroes con los que eran difíciles
de trabajar
idiota ha habido un montón de ellos que
son difíciles nuestro programa es uno
emocional hay muchas veces que las
personas no quieren realmente pasar por
el proceso am es difícil a veces se
quedan definitivamente lucho con eso
la voluntad no es binaria no es blanco o
negro no es sí o no bien en todas las
formas diferentes y amamos a todos
nuestros héroes por igual pueden algunos
de ellos será un dolor de cabeza a veces
si nos rendimos no
los pronombres deberían estar en todas
las casillas 3 2 1 ya
es difícil
tengo una pregunta antes de tomar una
decisión qué pasa si la persona no ha
descubierto sus pronombres todavía y se
sienten incómodos y no es algo con lo
que se sientan cómodos asignándole la
forma más fácil de que esas personas se
sientan cómodas es hacerlo obligatorio
pero si alguien en su viaje
todavía fuera la norma para que todos lo
tuviera me siento así siento que en
realidad voy a siento que hacer que
alguien se etiquete es lo que la
sociedad ya está tratando de hacer como
tú eres un hombre eres una mujer y
tienes que hacerlo creo que hacer que
alguien se etiquete antes de que esté
preparado es contra
producirse hoy tan dividido en este caso
porque puede estar en cualquier extremo
de esto y me siento en ambos extremos
creo que tenemos que darle tiempo a las
personas para averiguar quiénes son que
quieren ser y cómo se representan a sí
mismos la idea de tener que
identificarse con un pronombre siendo
algo tan aterrador demuestra hasta qué
punto deberíamos eliminar lo binario en
primer lugar porque es parte de la razón
por la que me identifico con él ella
porque no siento que haya encajado nunca
en lo binario así que me siento en
género fluido personalmente estoy
cansada de que me llamen mal y creo que
otras personas que viven fuera de lo
binario están hartas de ello creo que
eso facilitaría las cosas para las
personas si dijeran mira no hay más
el ella solo ahí ellos podría
suscribirlo pero si se les obliga a
descubrir una etiqueta entonces estamos
forzando a las personas a hacer algo con
lo que no se sientan cómodas es como si
forzar a alguien a tener un viaje muy
público antes de que pueda estar
preparado para ello y parte de la razón
por la que estoy así tal vez sea porque
tengo una confusión interna ahora con lo
sexual
espero segundo con la sexualidad y el
género porque para mí la sexualidad es
como si naciera gay y sintiera que no
puedo retirarla pero tal vez a tu punto
no es es diferente con el género no
puedo relacionarlo el género no es
importante
y
quizás lo entendido mal segura pregunta
es el género es importante no no lo es
no en el sentido de que no sea algo
importante en lo que pensar el viaje de
alguien con el género es importante pero
como la definición de género de alguien
no lo es necesaria mimar algunas
personas el género es increíblemente
importante para ellos y
eso ayuda a dictar quiénes son y quiénes
quieren llegar a ser y cómo llegan a
sentirse más cómodos creo que se ha
puesto demasiado énfasis en el género
especialmente por el comercialismo de
que el azul es para los niños el rosa es
para las niñas y esto es lo que define
el género creo que se ha definido
demasiado el género y creo que éste
debería ser fluido en lo que sientes por
dentro a mí realmente no me parece
importante pero como para algunas
personas es importante tenemos que
respetar eso y por lo tanto sí es
importante como como una comunidad de
humanos tiene sentido sí creo firmemente
que es importante debido a la violencia
contra las mujeres y las personas trans
en general así que para mí siento que es
importante porque hasta que no podamos
desmantelar
género binario que es tan opresivo y
asesino con el que vivimos siento que
bueno la idea de bobby es el objetivo sí
sí para mí y lo veo como una meta que no
no es importante
me encantó la intención genial me costó
mucho aceptar mi sexualidad dices que te
costó si no lo sabremos
321 ya
y yo vengo de una comunidad muy
conservadora como todos saben así que me
costó pensar cómo iba a ser mi futuro
siempre supe que era gay solo que no
sabía si iba a ser capaz de actuar sin
que me matarán así que fue difícil fue
difícil aceptarlo pero siempre supe que
era gay internamente no tenía problema
siento que sabía quién era y cuál era mi
verdad sentía que el mundo exterior
tenía un problema con esto yo luché con
ello un poco después de la pubertad
cuando me di cuenta de que me atraían
los chicos y las chicas sin embargo
incluso antes de cuidar había mucha
gente en mi vida que asumía que er
heterosexual conseguir ese trabajo que
mi vida cambiaría y todos los otros
trabajos me dieron una confianza que
antes no tenía la representación de los
queer en los medios de comunicación ha
mejorado mucho
no lo sé
el hecho de salir en televisión y no
quiero decir como si alguien me diera
permiso sino que el hecho de que haya
alguien como yo es alucinante nunca
pensé que mi vida una persona musulmana
gay morena estaría la televisión un
cabello perfecto un cabello precioso
cuando era pequeño la única persona que
había salido del closet era el em y
obvio eso no terminó bien para ella am
luego eran will and grace que ni
siquiera eran de cuando yo era pequeño
estaría en el inicio de mis 20 años y
todavía creo que hay un montón de
programas en donde hay cero
representaciones y no habrá porque ese
grupo demográfico no estará bien con
ellos todavía es noticia cada vez que
hay una historia queer tanto si se trata
de gente de color como de cualquier
persona que sigue causando un gran
revuelo y se trata como si fuera algo
importante aún no está normalizado
todavía hay películas que se prohíben en
los países incluso en dili tenemos
tantas legislaturas estatales que están
tratando de prohibir libros porque
porque son tontos
realmente estamos haciendo una
diferencia en el mundo
ayer por la mañana cuando me recogieron
en mi casa de camino al aeropuerto
un conductor blanco de 70 años se detuvo
y me subió al auto y me miró y dijo solo
tengo que decir que su programa ha
cambiado la vida de mi familia mi hija
tiene 27 años y está en proceso de
transición y no podíamos entenderlo no
entendíamos y vimos su programa porque
nos permite entender a nuestra hija y lo
que está pasando y ustedes han ayudado a
mi familia a sanar y estar ahí para
nuestra hija cuando no había forma de
hacerlo antes momentos como ese me hacen
sentir realmente orgulloso de lo que
hacemos y hacen que todo fluya ya saben
incluso en días de calor si debe valer
la pena
porque la razón por la que me detuve es
que pensaba que siempre hay más siempre
podríamos estar haciendo más progresando
pero siento que lo que estamos haciendo
lo que estamos aportando hace que
cambiemos las percepciones y siento que
estamos marcando la diferencia es así
como lo veo creo que es importante de
todas interacciones humanas que hemos
tenido es como si me siento muy abrumado
cuando las personas me detienen pero
nunca pasa de moda cuando hay familias
que te paran en un aeropuerto y dicen
este es un programa que podemos ver en
familia nunca pensé que iba a formar
parte de ese relato me sorprende que
puede parecer arrogante
sugerir que el trabajo que estamos
haciendo tiene un impacto en el mundo y
marca la diferencia sin embargo el hecho
de que niños de pakistán nos digan nunca
creí que hubiera un futuro para mí
pensaba que para cuando llegara a los 20
que es cuando se supone que nos casamos
tendría que suicidarme saber que estás
ahí afuera tienes una pareja tienes un
hijo has vivido una vida que era normal
para ti y sueño con que mi país sea como
el tuyo ese tipo de inspiración no tiene
precio no creo que ninguno de nosotros
pueda cuantificar realmente el impacto
que tenemos en los niños de los pueblos
en pakistán que nunca han creído que
tienen una vida más allá de los 20 años
eso es cambiar el mundo
gracias a todos todas las
karam o estábamos pensando no sé por qué
mira hacia arriba karam o estábamos
pensando demasiado pronto quiero dejar
claro que cara bueno se encuentra muy
bien ha vuelto seguimos siendo los 5
suscríbete ayuda para ver más de spector
quieres estar en un vídeo regístrate a
nuestro boletín informativo de castings
envíanos frases para nuevos episodios